In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinhaxadion for July 17th, on which we commemorate the Holy Great
Margarina.
The Holy Margarina lived during the reign of Emperor Claudius, circa 270.
She was from Pesidian Antioch, and the daughter of the idolatrous priest Adesimus.
Her mother, having died when she was 12 years old, she was placed in the care of a nurse
who lived in the country.
Association with Christians who lived in the area, along with the good natural disposition
of the girl, made the seeds of the true faith germinate very quickly in her heart.
When she had reached the age of 15, she was so consumed with love for Christ that she
desired and thought about one single thing to commune by the shedding of her blood in
the sacrifice that the martyrs made for the love of God.
Apart from keeping this desire's secret, she had no fear of proclaiming aloud that she
was a Christian, and she mocked the worship of idols.
This provoked her father's hatred, and he disinherited her.
Alibrius, prefect of Asia, being on the way to Antioch, met the saint while she was keeping
the flocks with other women from the village.
Charmed by her beauty, he told his men to bring her to him in order to make her his wife.
Arriving at the palace and brought before the magistrate who asked her to identify herself,
the girl declared with assurance.
My name is Marina, the daughter of free-born parents in Pasidia, but I am a servant of our
God and Savior, Jesus Christ, who made heaven and earth.
She was put in prison till the next day on which a great pagan feast was due, taken
again before the tribunal and urged to sacrifice to the gods with the rest of the people.
Marina replied, I will offer a sacrifice of praise to my God, but never to your dumb
and lifeless idols.
Alibrius pressed her to spare her youth and beauty, but she retorted that all carnal beauty
fades, while torture endured in Christ's name adorns the soul and prepares it for the
eternal marriage.
The magistrate, angered by her audacity, ordered that she be stretched out on the ground and
thrashed with thorny rods, and her flesh be lacerated with iron nails.
The saints blood spurred out in a great flood and reddened the ground, but she let out not
a single cry of pain, remaining imperturbable as though someone else were suffering in her place.
After having tortured her in this way for hours, they returned her to prison.
She was praying there to God not to abandon her in the trials and the confession of faith.
In an earthquake shook the prison, bringing a monstrous dragon out of its layer.
Fire and smoke belted from its eyes.
Its tongue was blood-red, and it made a terrible whistling noise as it moved towards the
saint.
Seized with great fear, Marina prayed to God the Savior who had reduced Satan to powerlessness
and freed the dead from hell by his cross.
The dragon changed itself into a huge and repulsive black dog.
The saint thenceforth strengthened by the grace of God, grabbed it by the skin, and seizing
hold of a hammer that was lying nearby, stopped the beast, placed her foot on its neck,
and killed it, smiting it on the head and the spine.
A brilliant light then appeared in the cell, shining from a huge cross on which a white
dove was perched.
The dove flew down beside Marina and said to her, rejoice, Marina, God's spiritual dove.
For you have overcome the evil one, and covered him with shame.
Rejoice, faithful servant of the God whom you love with all your heart, and for whom you
have abandoned all the transient pleasures of the earth.
Rejoice and be glad for the day has come for you to receive the crown of victory and to
enter fittingly clad with the wise virgins into the nuptial chamber of your spouse and
your king.
In the morning, Marina was summoned a second time before the governor's tribunal when she
showed a resolution even firmer than before, a liberious, ordered that she be stripped, naked,
and burned with torches.
After this torture, she was thrown headfirst into a water-filled cistern.
The dove then reappeared, bearing a branch in its beak, and the shining cross stood above
the cistern, from which the saint emerged free of her bonds.
The dove could be heard saying, come, Marina, and enjoy the rest reserved for the righteous.
In the face of this miracle, a great many of the pagans present confessed Christ and asked
the saint to instruct them in the doctrine of salvation.
Beside himself with fury, the governor ordered that they all be beheaded, along with Marina.
Arriving at the scaffold, Marina asked the executioners for a moment's prayer, and turning
eastwards, she begged the Lord to give health of soul and body to all who asked her intercession.
Having finished her prayer, she called on the executioner to do his work, but he, filled
with a devout fear, confessed Christ, and refused to lift his hand against the saint.
Marina then said to him, you have no part in me, unless you get on with what you have
been ordered to do, and with a trembling hand he beheaded her.
A Christian called Theotimos, who had secretly carried food to the saint when she was in prison,
took her body, and gave it worthy burial.
Until the time of the Crusades, in the year 1204, the relics of Saint Marina were venerated
in Constantinople, in the Church of Christ Pandepoptus.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.